as an architect when it comes to
designing a new house or
any commercial property there's one
thing that we truly have to consider
the site is so important and so critical
yet sometimes it's
so difficult to get a surveyor out on
site to
actually give you the information you
need
what's going on guys my name is david
thomaj and welcome back to the channel
today i'm going to show you exactly how
you can use an m1
ipad pro take it out onto site lidar
scan
that entire site basically creating a
3d map of the contours and the levels
the road
the shrubs the fences and everything
surrounding it
to be able to import it into archicad
and then create a
3d mesh from that information
now i have previously created a video on
m1 lidar scanning
but all of you guys wanted to see in
action in the real world
as an architect so last night i went out
onto site
next door to me there's a nice big empty
block and i lidar scanned the entire
property
it was my number one recommended app
back in that video if you haven't seen
it
go back and check it out there's a whole
bunch of different lighter scanning apps
out there that do
all sorts of different things but this
one personally resonated with me the
most so i really wanted to use it
outdoors
and test it out in a real-world
situation now full disclosure you have
to go
to the paid version of scandiverse to be
able to export it
out into archicad but thankfully they
give you a seven day free trial so you
can sign up and cancel your
subscription straight away if you just
want to test it out
i managed to figure out a few pros and
cons
with the scanning of the site itself
first of all
you can't scan any sort of shrubbery
any sort of wild grass or anything like
that
the lidar simply just doesn't pick it up
it'll try but all you'll see
is giant pink and red white lines on
your screen because it's not picking
anything up
so the site has to be relatively clear
and clean
thankfully in my situation most of the
site was predominantly
rock or sand or a little bit of really
light grass
it was able to pick up all of this
without a fault it really started to
struggle
in the very dark corners because i did
this at about 5
30 at night when the sun was setting and
it was getting really dark
because it's been raining here non-stop
so this was my only opportunity to go
out on site and actually
scan it with the lidar system it also
failed to pick up any of the wild grass
the really tall grass
so a lot of little bits and pieces were
just big empty holes that weren't
scanned
however i do believe it was able to pick
up a solid
98 maybe 99 of the site's
critical information that were needed
for me to take it into archicad and
actually develop a site mesh
okay so now we're going to take that 3d
lidar scan and import it directly into
arc cad
as always we're starting with the
australian select template
so it doesn't matter what you guys have
available just use the basic templates
supplied with your archicad version
scaniverse actually allows you to export
a whole number of
different actual file types so that you
can import
what you need into arcad archicad can
import a number of different file types
but
stl files seem to be the most compatible
with what we're trying to work with with
today now the easiest way to open up an
stl file from scanivers is going file
open open and selecting the file you
want to open
scaniverse has opened up here for us
today
now i have to warn you it is incredibly
slow even on my desktop so it is not
something that we want to be doing
all the time unless you want to be
ripping your hair out and being bold
very very quickly
but it does import the 3d mesh and it
gives you something
to work with so what i'm going to do is
actually orientate this mesh
properly and move it around as best as i
can so i'm just going to simply
draw a quick wall over here so i have my
point of reference
in 3d to actually orientate this entire
site
so moving into 3d we'll see that my wall
has been drawn
and that scan has come in at a very odd
angle
so that is the back of the block that is
the road up the top that we're speaking
of
so what we want to really do is find one
of these mesh points
near the road that i can tell is the
curb line
that's the road and that is the footpath
so
i'm gonna select this mesh in its
entirety
so let's try grab one of these endpoints
here
clicking on that tool dragging it all
the way to the corner of our wall
so we have an optimal position to work
from king the
command e button to open the orientate
tool which allows me to move replicate
and basically
do whatever i like with this site
mesh now i'm going to scroll around to
the back
fly to the back as much as i can select
my mesh
and select a vertical point on this
mesh to basically orientate it so i can
select that polygon
rotate it directly 90 degrees so i know
i have a
flat edge to work with so if i zoom back
out i should now be able to see
that is horizontally perfectly aligned
now all i have to do is select that mesh
once more
click command e once again rotate that
directly on my wall using it as my axis
holding shift
rotating it up 90 degrees and now by
clicking escape
in theory we should have that
site mesh orientated perfectly onto our
site as we see it now we can commence by
creating
a 3d mesh by using the mesh tool in
archicad
and slowly moving our points up to
create this
mesh like we see so let's delete this
wall that we've created before
simply clicking on it and tapping the
delete button again my computer is
running
so slow because of how much space and
how many polygons this mesh takes up
it kind of looks like a race car if you
look at it but that is the actual site
that we have scanned
road down here driveway coming up flat
bit of land
another bit of hill flat bit of land and
the fences around the side
now i'm not sure if you guys have
noticed but this channel has been
blowing up so firstly thank you so much
for joining this community it really
means a lot to me those of you who have
been on this channel for a very long
time have been asking the same questions
over and over again you're asking me all
the time how do i take my work to that
next level
how do i really stand out from the crowd
and how do i get a job in the profession
now today i've partnered up with zyro
who are today's video
sponsors they are a website building
platform that can help you take
your game to the absolute next level
with their platform you can literally
build a whole digital portfolio in a
matter of minutes
or even sell your digital designs online
and reach a much bigger audience than
you ever could before
the possibilities with xyro are actually
limitless the best part about csiro
is they're nothing like their
competition they are so
so affordable their customer service is
24 7
round the clock and their website load
times are lightning fast the last thing
you want to do is
spend all of your time building a
beautiful website and then people
clicking on it
waiting for it to load it didn't take me
long to figure out the drag and drop
system of xyro
it was very very simple you find a
beautiful template out of hundreds
that they have available you've picked
your favorite one
and you basically just start going
through and changing all the elements to
suit you
your brand and what you're trying to
create so
even when i did get stuck thankfully
they have 24 7 support so i didn't have
to sneak in a quick email
during business hours i could literally
just ask them any time of day or night
to help me out
i think the best part about xyro though
is the simple fact that you don't need
any coding knowledge whatsoever now
obviously i have a very good background
in technology and i.t
as well as architecture but truly i
didn't really stumble upon any giant
hiccups
that anybody wouldn't be able to do so
if you are a novice looking to just
start your first website
zyra is the perfect place to start even
if you're an experienced website builder
looking to
innovate and improve on your digital
marketing or your ecommerce store
this is exactly what you're looking for
and as we all know
everybody's moving away from the
computer and onto the tablet
xyro is fully cross-compatible between
your mobile devices
your tablets and your desktop so all you
have to do is create
one beautiful website and the rest is
done by xyro now because i don't like
teaming up with companies
that basically give me something and
give you nothing
i truly wanted to make sure that this
partnership was mutual across the board
so xyro has been generous enough to give
you guys
three months free with any yearly
purchase
so if you want to get three months free
on your website
check out the link down below it is the
very first
link in the description box otherwise
you can literally just type in my name
david thomas in the checkout and get
that discount automatically applied what
we're going to do
is simply select our mesh tool and
then commence by drawing a simple square
so let's use the basic geometry tool i'm
probably going to go
to the outskirts a little bit selecting
the basic
geometry polygon tool i'm going to go
around the edges
of this fence line that i'm assuming
is the fence clicking ever so
generically at this point in time
to create our generic square
mesh that will go underneath now if we
come back into 3d we'll see we've
created our mesh underneath
now there are two ways of doing this
mesh and
one's the quick and easy way and one is
the painstaking way that
you will absolutely go crazy about so
the quickest and easiest way to do this
which is still a little bit time
consuming is simply
dragging the absolute pinnacle of that
mesh that you created
all the way past so it surpasses
our scanned 3d mesh making sure that the
perimeter of our mesh covers
all of our scanned site plan
that we're trying to duplicate so we can
get rid of this
3d scan and speed up our computer so
we're going to
drag out the sides just a little bit
further
and then we're going to right click
connect
solid element operations we're going to
get this
dialog box pop up over here we're going
to add that as a target operator we're
going to deselect
the new mesh we've created we're going
to select our morph
which is our scanned stl file we're
going to add that as our
operator and we're going to subtract
with an upwards
extrusion and then all we're going to do
is hit execute
wait a very long amount of time for this
to process
and then we're going to start dragging
and dropping a few of the little bits
and pieces
so all the areas that we missed on that
scan
are in line with where they should be
okay so now if i
close my solid element operations open
up my layers
and look for morph
general i can turn that off and hide our
morph
so now our computer will function so
much quicker
and we can see that we've cut most of
this
mesh to where it should be now obviously
it isn't perfect there's all these
pinnacles
all the way through but we can adjust
that now with the computer operating a
lot quicker
okay so we don't actually need all of
this extra
on the outside now so what we're going
to do is simply
drag back in our mesh
just like we dragged it out before so we
can cut off a large section of
unnecessary land
it's going to take a little bit of time
to process i'm going to work my way
through
around all four edges and jump back to
you guys relatively quickly okay so now
we've trimmed off all the edges and
we have a general sight left over
there's still a few little bits and
pieces here that you can see that are
sticking out way too much
because the sight and the scan just
wasn't able to pick it up
but we can see a majority of how the
actual site works
relatively well so the best thing we can
do now is go back to our ground floor
plan
add a series of hotspots around so we
can adjust it in
3d again so moving back to our story
zero
all we're going to do is go to the mesh
tool double click
and start adding a few hotspots around
now when we go back to 3d we simply
click on our mesh we'll see all those
hot spots added
and what we're going to do is spin the
camera around to the side
and slowly adjust each one of these hot
spots
to the edge of our actual mesh
so again this is going to take a little
bit of time all i'm going to do is click
on one
adjust the elevation point mesh drag it
down
all the way i'll probably drag it
exactly to where the mesh is press ok
and let it do its thing i'll work my way
around as again this is going to take a
significant amount of time
it isn't the most ideal method and the
most ideal approach
but it is very good to know how much
technology has progressed
and what we are able to do in a limited
amount of time okay and there we have it
i've made my entire way around this
model
dragging all those hotspots all the way
to the bottom and
finishing off with what is as close
to our mesh underneath as possible
now as you can see that morph underneath
is still
basically contributing to the overall
look and feel of this site mesh
but what we have done is successfully
replicated a land
mass on archicad by simply using
our ipad and the technology inside
archicad
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed the video i hope you
learned something with this
lidar scanning for the m1 ipad pro
with a real life scenario placed in
front of you
i will be taking this design further as
the channel continues to progress
i'll be putting an actual design onto
this site mesh
and creating more archicad content for
you guys to follow along and learn
if that's something that interests you
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below
to join this community there is a
discord link
down below as well if you want to join
the private chat community
filled with architects designers
students from across the entire world
just basically helping each other grow
as individuals and professionals but
that is all from me today guys
thank you so much for being a part of
this community like always
i will see you next monday